>> Hi, so I'm here to talk about RingDroid.
RingDroid is a--Android App that let’s you
edit your own ring tones from existing music
on your SD card. So I'm going to demo it right
now. Now, you’ll see that when RingDroid
starts up you see of a list of available music
that you have, and I am now going to edit
one of my songs and make it into my ring tone.
Notice how RingDroid starts up with a waveform
and with this waveform you can actually see
what you’re editing and you can move it
around. So I’m going to drag it around and
show you how this works. And now after I’ve
dragged it around, I can play a preview to
see if this is actually what I wanted to hear
for my ring tone. If I feel happy about it,
I can go edit and save it. Now I can set it
as my default ring tone. Even better than
that, RingDroid is also great for developers
because with a very simple intent call developers
can use RingDroid inside their own application.
So I'm going to show a quick, very quick demo
of that which is, which is a--there is the
app called the sound port. There is--there
is the app called the sound port which lets
you use--which let’s you create your own
goofy sound board--of goofy sounds, and it
lets the users set their own thing. So I'm
going to start that. Now the idea behind sound
board is that the user can create their own
icons, create their own sounds, and do whatever
they want, and they edit their sounds by using
RingDroid.
So I'm going to create a button here with
the RingDroid sound. And now, if I try to
pick a sound clip, they’re all I’m taping.
And so now, while I try to take a sound clip
here, it’s going to use RingDroid. So, I
just clicked the Run RingDroid button, and
that is how I’ve now started RingDroid from
this other application.
And so now I can cut this piece of music out
and, voila! Now I’ve made a sound porter
that uses that piece of music I’ve selected.
And there you go. So this is how you can use
RingDroid in another application. Thank you
for watching and search for RingDroid at Android
Market. It’s free and open forth, so go
out there and grab it. See you.